welcome back to CBS this morning the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex are taking an
extended leave from the Royal Duty
starting next month now this comes as
Prince Harry and his wife Megan Marco
get candid in a new documentary about
their struggles with the media's intense
scrutiny of their personal lives
the royal couple spoke to journalist Tom
Bradby during their recent tour of
Africa about the complicated
relationship with the press Elizabeth
Palmer's at Buckingham Palace with more
on this story Elizabeth they do appear
to be opening up in ways they haven't
before what are we learning from this
documentary well some frank admissions
including Megan saying that before she
married Harry her friends warned her not
to because the UK media specifically the
tabloids would destroy her life and
indeed it does seem as she's finding
things pretty stressful I never thought
that this would be easy but I thought it
would be fair in the documentary Megan
Markel now Duchess of Sussex says out
loud what many observers had guessed she
is finding the near constant critical
scrutiny as a royal very hard any woman
when they're especially when they're
pregnant you're really vulnerable so
that was made really challenging and
then when you have a newborn it's a lot
the documentary follows Prince Harry and
Megan on a tenday southern Africa trip
that they took to bring attention to
various charities on camera Megan speaks
about her bruising clashes with the
British tabloid press I really tried to
adopt this British sensibility of a
stiff upper lip I think that what that
does internally is probably really
damaging on the last day of the tour
Megan and Harry sued one of those
British tabloids for what they say was a
smear campaign the paper had printed a
very personal and painful letter from
Megan to her father Prince Harry who
grew up watching his mother Princess
Diana being hounded by those tabloids
was furious every single time I hear a
click every single time I see a flash it
takes me straight back since their
wedding Harry and Megan have tried to
keep their private
private but that in itself has drawn
criticism asked whether he and his
brother Prince William are on the outs
Harry dodged the question I love him
dearly and the majority of the stuff is
probably well the majority of stuff is
created out of nothing but you know it's
just as brothers you know good days you
have bad days
royal correspondent Roy Anika they are
breaking the mold within the institution
to a certain degree everything they're
doing is being held to account
almost more closely and with more
scrutiny than on members and more from
it at the moment the bottom line seems
to be that if a big part of the royal
role is de-facto being on public display
then maybe finding the right work-life
balance is the hardest part of the job
Tony
Elizabeth Palmer forests in London thank
you very much Liz it is a candid
conversation that documentary and
normally not done in the Royals I think
it's good that they're speaking so
candidly and so honestly I'm curious to
see how it's gonna play in the UK I love
Megan saying in particular and never
thought it would be easy but I thought
it would be fair that's the problem that
they're having they don't think that
it's fair and many untruths are being
said about what Harry sensitivity to
what his mother Gord is you have to be
sympathetic to that how he's still
haunted by it there's the attention of
Fame and then there's what they are
going through it's not a little bit
different